[Musique]
fasel monsieur bonjour le pape jean paul
ii n'a pas beaucoup dormi la nuit
dernière il s'est couché après minuit et
dès ce matin 8h30 le saint père a
rencontré à la nonciature les
représentants des confessions
chrétiennes non catholique jacques le
noir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour commencer cette deuxième journée
parisienne jean paul ii tient deux
réunions la première avec une vingtaine
d'intellectuels français
oui alors il n'y a pas eu de miracle le
journal commence mal alors expliquez moi
ce qui se passe oui alors nous
commençons par quel sujet ils ne sont
pas prêts sur l'a14 intéressant oui bon
très bien alors nous allons donc
commencer ce journal excusez nous nous
avons un petit problème technique
nous allons donc commencer ce journal
par la matinée du pape jean paul ii à
l'elysée qui a été reçue sous la pluie
par le président valéry giscard
d'estaing
vous l'avez peut-être suivie en direct
sur tf le français patrick pons sera
peut-être pour la première fois dans
l'histoire des sports mécaniques excusez
moi oui nous pouvons reprendre le rail
et bien heureusement car j'étais en
train de dérailler merci alors nous
allons reprendre le rail d'ouessant
autrement dit le reportage de jean
pierre qui tarde sur ce fameux rail
d'ouessant
oui ce sont les ptt ou c'est la
télévision oui nous sommes à nouveau en
panne
c'est amusant non nous ne sommes pas le
premier avril donc j'ai essayé de
poursuivre ce journal en gardant mon
calme donc je vous disais que le
français patrick pons sera peut-être
pour la première fois dans l'histoire
des sports mécaniques champion du monde
de motocyclisme
il suffirait que ponce obtient en effet
une simple place d'honneur cet après
midi à rijeka au grand prix de
yougoslavie oui vous n'avez plus rien du
tout bien alors on met la clé sous la
porte on s'en va qu'est ce qu'on fait
oui oui non je ne quitte pas vous ne
quittez pas non plus un mais vous mettez
à ma place aussi merci
alors le rail d'ouessant est prêt oui a
dit don tout ça est bien amusant donc le
rail d'ouessant troisième espoir de ma
part j'espère que nous allons pouvoir
suivre ce reportage de jean pierre
guittard qui devrait arriver sur nos
écrans de télévision dans une seconde
[Musique]